bello a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo momento sono fa vj ed oggi siamo
sulla iss layers ma non ha manco leggere
sul layer software che praticamente un
videogame che avevo fatto tempo fa
l'avevo anche finito ed è uscito ragazzi
il tlc neelie la sofia che si chiama
inheritance che non so che cosa voglia
dire proprio sto quadro è veramente figo
per chi non conoscesse la il software è
praticamente un gioco dove ci sono dei
quadri brutti c'è qualcuno che sta
entrando da qualche passi crisi in sé
week end fgm premi f per accendere la
torcia e mi chiama in italiano full che
figata ragazzi non ci posso credere è la
prima volta che gioco un gioco horror
così tradotto beni italiano che bello
per terra avevo giocato alla il software
però non certo che c'è più ordine
qualche in camera mia comunque
[Musica]
e qualcuno che sta suonando sta roba o
me lo sto sognando io non so se l'ha con
il bello che quando parte nostra
musichette negli horror non si capisce
se le sta suonando qualcuno oppure si
sono messe a caso non si capisce vabbè
ma dove devo andare la calma spiegatemi
qualcosa questo masters quest'anno a non
lo so io va bene visto che c'è il bel
tempo fuori non ne ho idea guardavia
cazzo sono con mi ricorda quando finiva
i fogli a scuola che dovevo prendere
appunti sul banco mite che figo
ho sentito un rumore non mi potete
stavolta hanno sentito sul serio se c'è
qualcuno di sopra si faccia vedere che
bello ragazzi a amo questi videogames mi
giurò di qua è chiusa grazie a dio è
chiusa mica che bello sono contentissimo
che sia chiusa mi chiamano male comunque
ragazzi la storia io a vela accenno
perché la so c'è l'ho letta notizia
questa che sto comandando io viveva in
questa casa da piccola ed è scappata
perché il suo padre la trattava male
perché so che questa cosa e sfocata che
cazzo è così sono morto so chi però stai
calmo
papà ma che cazzo dipingi è scemo io non
ho capito se sta roba qua se la sta
sognando lei o se si stimano la nostra
sta sognando
e vabbè andava a fuoco il pavimento zio
nati non mischiamo tirateli un cazzotto
forte ma quello è il quadro che ha fatto
bello ma io ero messo vita così se io
sto in questa posizione va bene non ho
ben capito il perché suo padre fosse
così ossessionato dal fare i quadri per
ove ancora devi ricordare perché devi
sempre ricordare ma sono io da piccola è
la madonna quanto vediate le porte
aprire promesso ciao papà mi fai un
altro quadro bello l'app accadono le
cose dal soffitto
va bene papà mamma a qualcuno non c'è
nessuno profondo sta andando a fuoco
hanno al camino dove la tipa che sta
parlando nessuno
[Musica]
monaco e by dici di no ok adesso sì che
ho capito ovviamente ragazzi questo lo
spartito in la maggiore di andiamo a
comandare un problema nella testa un
problema nel pianoforte funziona a metà
ogni tanto parte un suono che fa
esattamente così
devo continuare a cliccare il tasto
finché non si scassa e avena idea che il
cray lance vai a prendere i tuoi colori
i colori mi dispiace se non sono stato
in grado di suonare questa cosa ma non
me ne intendo proprio salve e non posso
uscire o bello normale michele era
orribile sostanza dio mio
non mi fa non mi fate cadere cose dal
suo affitto per favore non mi fate dire
che odio
beh vabbè mamma lo giuro che non sono
stato io lo giuro stavo suonando
pianoforte mai visto
mi spiegate dove sto andando vi prego
c'è un rileva beh se vi lamentate dei
compiti a casa che mi danno i posti prof
guardate questa roba ecco perfetto i
miei erano più o meno così nasce
un'altra porta che sarà perlomeno chiusa
noi invece aperta che strano ciao ciao
ciao io sono famiglie e pronti o sono
una bambina
ti va di giocare
lo dico alla mamma che sei stata tu e
non potevano raccontare una storia senza
far cadere niente nessuno scaffale
[Musica]
prendo io zio
negrini
i giuro che ho fatto del mio meglio
credimi è una stanza trasformata in un
vagone di un treno va bene ma posso
anche muovermi uomo perché si small e
colato un bar
[Applauso]
minchia lampadari in faccia forte
ragazzi è diventato in un secondo si è
trasformato in among the sleep tuo gioco
non so se abbiamo e ricorda monte slim
pro am è troppo e bellissimo quando
possono zoomare con la faccia sta cosa
qua non l'ho mai capita negli horror gli
ha fatto ah ecco ho trovato la è la
madonna ho fatto io con la mia colpa mi
ha sorriso risorto perché c'è un cervo
che cola che cazzo ne va bene rompo il
vaso nel dubbio perfetto tipo anima
stiamo entrando nell'altare di satana
cos'è sta roba
ciao tesoro si sia arrivo arrivo vieni
aspetta eccomi 97 cazzo sei andata
tesoro aspetta però aspetta c'è una
torta di compleanno
non sappiamo come si chiama st cristiani
o trovate a inventarvi un nome non ci
avevate voglia la pigrizia acqua devo
farmi tipo scala l'ho fatto vai vai vai
vai veloce veloce dove stiamo andando
ma come con sé ma com'è che questo gioco
cambia a caso no no no no no no sono un
idiota
devo andare avanti tentando di non
cadere va bene dovrebbe essere
abbastanza sembra la smetti di comparire
sparire piquet come vestita poi siamo
una bambola horror piano piano come ezio
come ezio come ezio non faceva così ezio
sono fuori credo di s
il caso da tempo i fermenti sa spiegarmi
perché succedono queste cose io sarei
molto contento di scoprirlo perché in
teoria st bambina dovrebbe ricordare
eventi passati del padre cattivo allora
perché cazzo sorgono gli scaffali questa
roba non l'ho capita perché ora da
ragazzi con colloqui il primo episodio
di lei a soffrire perché è molto
spirituale come horror un po strano che
mi piace in tutta sincerità è solo un po
difficile da capire a volte ma comunque
a vela e continuo nel prossimo episodio
quasi da ragazze video vissuto il suo
momento è un mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook come invito a tornare
descrizione superstiti siete i civili
diamo il prossimo video per ragazzi